i'm on problem number seven
josephine's daily exercise routine
consists of swimming cycling running in
that order so swimming
cycling
running
running in that order
she runs faster than she swims runs
faster than swimming so she runs faster
than she swims
and cycles faster than she runs like
most people
if she does not rest between the
activities which of the following could
be the graph of the distance she covers
during the entire time of her exercise
routine so i'm not giving a look at the
choices and i'll just give you an
intuition and then you can look for the
choices that matches
so if i were to graph
distance
versus time
the slope of my line is going to be my
speed right because what is speed it's
distance per time and that's the same
thing it's as slope it's rise over run
so in this context that would be the
slope of the line so what you want is a
situation she swims first which is her
slowest
then she cycles which is her fastest
then she runs which is kind of in
between so what you're going to have is
a low slope then a very high slope and
then you want kind of a medium slope so
it's going to look something like this
because she's she swims first so that's
the slowest exercise so maybe it'll be
like that
then she cycles which is her fastest
exercise so maybe it'll look something
like that and then she runs which is
kind of an in-between exercise so maybe
it looks something like this
so which of the choices looks like that
where you start relatively slow you peek
out pretty fast
and then you do something that looks a
little bit faster that has a higher
slope than this and if i look at all of
the choices
it looks like
choice
d e choice e is actually pretty
pretty close to what i drew
if you look at the other choices choice
a she goes slow
then
medium then fast so that's like if she
cycled last right
and choice b she does her slow thing
last so that looks like she's swimming
last choice c looks like she's swimming
last as well because that's the slowest
and then choice d looks like she cycles
then she swims then she runs so it's
definitely choice e you go slow fast and
then medium
next problem
problem eight
in the x y coordinate system square root
of six
sorry the point is square root of 6
comma k
is one of the points of intersection of
the graphs so these are the graphs y
is equal to x squared minus 7
and
y is equal to minus x squared
minus x squared
plus
j
fair enough where j is a constant what
is the value of j
so we know the x coordinate where it
intersects right we know it intersects
at square root of 6. so intersection
means that the y values are the same for
a given x value that's what
intersects so we can set these two
equations equal to each other so we
could say
x squared we can set the y values equal
to each other x squared minus 7
is equal to this
minus x squared
plus j
now we could keep things in terms of x
or we could
um
well let's let let's just algebraically
play with this a little bit and i hope
you understand that this is this
represent this is what we would do to
solve for the intersection of these two
graphs if we wanted to solve for the x
value and we could play with this a
little bit we could add x squared to
both sides you get 2 x squared minus
seven
is equal to j
and what's x we know where these
intersect we know one of the points
where they intersect is square root of
six
so let's intersec let's
input let's replace x with square root
of 6.
so 2 times
square root of 6 squared minus 7 is
equal to j
what's the square root of 6 squared well
it's just 6 right
so it's 2 times 6 minus 7 is equal to j
so 12 minus 7 is equal to j
5 is equal to j and that is choice a
problem 9.
problem nine
if the absolute value of two minus x
is less than three
which of the following is a possible
value of x
so this means that 2 minus x
that means that 2
minus
x
is less than 3
right
so i guess the way you can think about
it the difference between 2 and x is
going to be less than
3 right the other way you could view it
is
is that
the negative of this
x minus 2
is going to be less than three
right we could have also said two or we
could have said two minus x is greater
than negative three that's the other
thing we could have written and what i
did is i just
this is either going to be a positive or
a negative right so if it's a positive
we just say 2 minus x is less than 3. if
x is going to be greater than 2 then we
could say that x minus 2 is less than 3
because then it would be a negative
number then it would become positive
hope i didn't confuse you so if this is
true you'd get let's see
you would get
if i were to add x to both sides you get
is less than 3 plus x
subtract 3 from both sides you get
negative 1 is less than x this one add 2
to both sides you get x is less than
5.
so x is greater than negative 1 and it
is less than 5.
so if you look at all of the choices
if you look at all the choices
choices
has to be less than five
and
greater than negative one
so out of all of those choices the only
choice that is less than 5 is choice a
which is 4.
and if you could look at it you could
actually just try out the numbers
and frankly if even if you got confused
by absolute value you could have just
tried each of the choices two minus four
is minus two absolute value which
absolute value of negative two is just
two which is less than three so that's
right so you could have actually just
tried out the choices if this confused
you and that actually might have been
faster because there's only worst case
you'd have to try out five choices and
each of them would have taken a few
seconds to evaluate
but sometimes it's good to do it
mathematically but
i wouldn't wrong you for
i wouldn't blame you for just trying
things out as well
10 okay
if all interior angles of the polygon
are congruent then x is equal to okay so
this is interesting so
all of the angles of this polygon are
congress it's a pentagon that's one
two
like that two
three
four
and five i didn't draw them really that
congruent
and actually this line keeps going like
this
and the important thing to realize with
any of these triangles is
if i were to draw
there's a formula for
the angles of a polygon but i always
so the way to think about it is is that
these are all going to be
equal angles
so think of a think of it think of it
this way these are five
equal triangles
let me think of it the best way so we
they're telling us we want to figure out
what
this
x degrees is right
well this x degrees is going to be the
same as this x degrees
and how do i know that